this is Apple's new flagship San
Francisco retail space this is the next
generation of Apple Retail Apple is
celebrating the 15th anniversary of its
retail stores and to celebrate they're
giving us a look at this one which
they're calling the future of retail but
you don't enter the future through doors
like this you come through doors like
these these massive sheets of glass open
to a new indoor/outdoor feel a design
language that will be integrated into
new stores around the globe Apple's
retail aesthetic has long been as clean
as a space station but now there are
indoor trees and soon a greenery fills
public courtyard the hangar sized doors
slide open 40 feet that's wide enough
for Apple to sell things much larger
than phones and laptops like say a car
maybe at the new stores designed by
architects Foster and partners products
and accessories are still displayed with
the sort of precise design and care that
we've come to expect from Apple but
there are new touches or no touches as
it were a wave of a hand opens power and
connectivity ports at tables stores will
now be start with not only geniuses but
also creative pros ready to help with
music and design questions or to assist
with headphones or camera accessories
and there's no more Genius Bar
you know sometimes having to get your
phone fixed is like going to the dentist
and so we said how do we make it the
most calming the most inviting
environment customers will now get their
Apple hardware serviced in the
tree-lined genius grove this main second
floor space with views over San
Francisco's Union Square is called the
forum and will host musical performances
and talks by photographers and app
developers very few companies would take
20% of their real estate in a very
expensive store and dedicated simply
dedicated to entertaining and helping
small entrepreneurs Apple perhaps better
than any other tech company has long
understood the importance of
presentation touch and service in the
physical retail space the company wants
the new stores to be places where people
choose to just come and hang out at the
weekend so get there early for a seat in
the genius Grove
you